[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'ancient
parler sport l'émission à ne pas manquer
si vous êtes un amoureux de sport local
aujourd'hui au programme une dose de
bonne humeur des analyses sportives et
surtout des coups de gueule et des
débats nos chroniqueurs sont avec nous
en plateau ou via écran interposé pour
décortiquer toute l'actualité sportive
yvelinoise présentation musique
il est de retour et sur ce plateau c'est
l'un des pères fondateurs de cette
émission il l' a toujours cette énergie
pour décortiquer cette actualité
sportive évinois c'est un pistard il
vient du club de vélizy 78 le capitaine
qui a déjà riez et avec nos bons sens
michael quand avez-vous super plein
d'énergie plein dévoué plein d'énergie
ben oui puisqu'on n'a pas en revanche
aux pour la dépense et on l'a concernant
là on emmagasine pour cette émission ça
va péter ça va péter quand on va
reprendre vous assure que ça va être de
la folie
bon on va voir si vous habitez dans
cette émission en tout cas alors on
passe de l'autre côté afin musique c'est
une véritable encyclopédie vivante sur
le sport yvelinois vous pouvez tout lui
demander il vous répondra à toujours
c'est la star de cette émission son
surnom l'italian lovers le très élégant
l'incroyable talent tué grégory canale
est avec nous bonjour michael bonjour à
tous quand allez-vous bas pour être tout
à fait honnête avec vous un peu dans le
dur après les déconvenues en joutes
européennes de mon équipe de coeur donc
on va dire que hélas la juventus en
ligue des champions donc cette démission
est enregistrée début mars qui a été
éliminé par le fc porto donc on va dire
que le sop c'est un peu ma thérapie mon
antidote mon vaccin c'est le terme
utilisé en ce moment donc prêt à
débattre avec les copains en tout cas
yann est en face de vous et les autres
justement les présentes nous sont donc
trois en plateau les autres sont avec
nous via écran interposé à cause du
contexte sanitaire musique vous
reconnaissez forcément ça
musique c'est également l'un des piliers
de cette émission en parlant de pilier
c'est notre spécialiste rugby il nous
vient tout droit de versailles
le gladiateur pierre chevallier et avait
pu pierre chevallier comment allez-vous
haut revient à fournir les copains
heureux de vous retrouver comme
d'habitude en pleine forme et en pleine
forme au pluriel au site est ce que
laisse a commencé à durer un petit peu
ce couvre-feu et on va parler rugby dans
cette émission un petit peu plus tard et
notamment de la fin de la saison
sportive je sais que vous êtes très
remonté là dessus on sinon là alors lui
aussi est connecté via écran interposé
musique c'est une légende vivante
également c'est un mythe c'est notre
expert rugby c'est le boute en train de
cette émission ces gens miss tout
simplement coach jean miss ex-entraîneur
du rugby un plaisir
quel suspense aujourd'hui gaël lui à
tous oui vous avez l'art de mettre le
suspense en place incessamment vous êtes
un petit peu le spielberg et cessa de
l'émission oui on a beaucoup
enfin lui aussi est connecté via écran
interposé musique
il est de retour dans cette émission
après plusieurs mois d'absence c'est un
à plaisir de le recevoir il nous a
manqué elle vous a manqué notre vengeur
masqué raoult le côté d'autres et
cavalier international est avec nous
raul ou je suis ravi de vous revoir
depuis temps on est ravi de vous revoir
également vous êtes en forme
oui parfaitement vous avez passé pénal
vous avez bossé l'émission vont
apparemment ce n'est pas forcément le
cas de tout le monde parce que j'ai
entendu avant l'émission qui pompe hier
on marchera ou talent
alors avant de passer au programme de
l'émission justement à parler football
il se souviendra de ce samedi 27 février
pendant longtemps l'yvelinois edouard
michu a joué ses premières minutes chez
les professionnels avec le paris saint
germain le joueur de 17 ans était entré
en jeu à la 88e minute lors de la
victoire du psg face à dijon en quatre
buts à zéro il a remplacé danilo pereira
blessés ce billet de terrain évinois est
passé par les clubs du chéné de
versailles avant d'intégrer le paris
saint-germain on devrait le revoir sous
les couleurs du club de la capitale il a
signé un contrat professionnel jusqu'en
2023 votre avis tout simplement sur ce
premier match de michu la nouvelle
pépite peut-être du psg pierre
chevallier évidemment bourrin versailles
est un chef désigné je ne peux que
m'enthousiasmer sur sur l'actualité la
qualité de la formation sportive quel
que soit le sport dans les élus
et puis me réjouir pour que murray joue
et lui souhaitait vraiment le meilleur
parce qu'elle a 18 ans quand ça commence
comme ça ça promet vraiment il faut
juste qu'ils se brûle pas les aides mais
on a on a là une toute belle pépite qui
devient de du département et qui
commence à faire ses armes au contact
des plus grands banques vont à lui
grégory comment ce petit à petit c'est
très bien pour lui n'entrait la 88e
minute de jeu face à dijon deux
convocations pour la ligue des champions
face au fc barcelone que ce soit pour le
match aller où pour le match retour donc
ça ça commence bien pour lui et je pense
que c'est aussi bien pour le psg qui
essayent de plus en plus de valoriser sa
formation de valoriser ces petits titi
parisien comme on les appelle on a vu
par le passé que des titi comme clic
c'est laid comme anne même adrien radio
un peu plus tard avait un peu plus de
mal à s'imposer et partaient des fois de
chez des ennemis européen donc c'est
bien que le psg puisse pour le moment
conserver ce petit jeune donc non en
force force à lui et le début de
carrière qui commence sous de bons
auspices raul est ce qu'il faut
peut-être le faire jouer tout de suite
où il faut attendre un petit peu
peut-être lui faire grappiller quelques
minutes par ci par là je pense que
quand il ya quand on a peu d'expérience
à ce niveau là il vaut mieux prendre le
temps de faire ses marques et non pas se
brûler les ailes tout de suite faut
qu'ils puissent se concentrer sur son
équipe aussi parce que je crois qu'il a
été il a été il a fait l'objet de
beaucoup de sollicitations de notamment
du de dieu de ces barcelone donc je
crois qu'il faut y aller progressivement
avec des jeunes des jeunes talents comme
ça on n'est pas forcément le griller
tout de suite si je comprends bien non
voilà j'en qu'est ce que vous en pensez
de ce petit michu levée elle c'est la
suite logique d'un des jeunes qui issus
du centre de formation
il y en a énormément il n'a très peu
qu'un sorte lui l'amf est parti c'est
certainement une future star du football
l'adresse de la suite logique est il
rentre quelques minutes
et puis s'il continuera à prendre à
prendre des galons en jouant de plus en
plus de deux ans au sein de l'équipe
mais pour l'instant c'est normal et il
ya l'équipe à faire tourner aussi mais
on ne peut pas intégrer un jeune comme
ça dans un collectif
alors qui le psg veut des résultats
avant tout donc c'est normal la suite
logique qu'on lui souhaite
le plus grand bien et le verso du
verrier faux pas peut être le prêter ce
jeune peut-être pour qu'il s'aguerrisse
ailleurs c'est ce qui se fait souvent
dans football ben moi je trouve ça
dommage
voilà je pense que quand tu as un joueur
et qu'il est bon ben c'est pas dans le
béton chez l'adversaire que qui va le
fou qui va être qui va être formée donc
oui le temps de jeu est important
maintenant l'esprit qu'une équipe peut
développer dans le temps fait passe
peut-être justement par la formation de
ses propres jeunes et de les former en
interne donc donc non moi je pense que
c'est bien oui en effet entré à la 88e
pour préciser cette rentrée pour débuter
maintenant je pense qu'il va être assez
près il va être peut être pas impatient
mais il va avoir envie de pouvoir
rentrer sur
sur des quarts d'heure et puis après
vous faut peut-être aussi que paris
utilise dès aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on
en a à que paris gagne là alors
il n'existe plus d'ailleurs la coupe de
la ligue ou alors la coupe de france
attention votre langage
qu'est ce qu'on va faire que paris gagne
la coupe de france ou une coupe une
couple lambda du je pense que il devrait
peut-être utiliser certains premier tour
de ce type de compétition pour justement
donné l'expérience assez assez jeune ça
permet de faire tourner l'effectif de
faire faire des matches en moins aux
stars et donc à ces jeunes de leur dire
voilà là tu vas avoir quelques matchs en
coupe de france c'est beaucoup une
époque beaucoup tu le faisais jouer le
troisième gardien en couple ou le
deuxième gardien pour pour le laisser un
petit peu dans l'idaho même à ce même
titre des joueurs de champ leur dire bas
cette année pour toi c'est la coupe de
france et est donc du coup c'est là
qu'ils vont avoir envie de 2,2 de
données et de montrer qu'ils sont qui
sont capables de prendre de prendre
place plus tard oui c'est une bonne
option peut-être de le mettre dans la
rotation grégory si l'intégration
progressive la coupe de france
effectivement je suis d'accord avec iad
sur sur ce point là c'est une
compétition idéale pour faire tourner un
peu l'effectif et faire jouer les
équipes les équipes b d'autant plus si
paris va un peu plus loin en ligue des
champions faudrait aussi économiser des
forces et aussi économiser des forces
pour le championnat où on sait que ça va
être très dur avec lille le losc qui
également tient la course en tête donc
pour faire tourner l'effectif et faire
aussi de l'expérience à ce petit jeune
michu mais aussi pour les autres jeunes
du psg je pense que la coupe de france
effectivement ça peut être une bonne
option
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
avons parlé à de rugby donc la
fédération française annoncé une saison
blanche pour le rugby amateur ce que
c'était la bonne décision à prendre nous
allons tenter de répondre à cette
question coup de projecteur également
sur tony you call boxeurs yvelinois
remporter son dixième combat chez les
professionnels peut-il devenir champion
du monde mais avant de développer ces
thèmes on va parler cyclisme
[Musique]
on va donc parler cyclisme et plus
précisément du paris-nice l'événement
est partie à des yvelines pour la
douzième année consécutive la 79e
édition de la course au soleil s'est
lancé ce dimanche depuis la commune de
saint cyr l'école c'était une grande
première pour la commune du département
en écoute
la maire de la ville au micro de tv 78
c'est une vraie opportunité pour la
ville de faire connaître ses bâtiments
historiques l'école militaire liée à thé
l'aérodrome
mais aussi de montrer à quel point cette
ville elle est agréable à vivre et
et pour nous c'est un vrai bonheur après
saint cyr l'école c'était au tour de
watteville sur mansion d'accueillir
l'épreuve
ce lundi 8 mars cette petite commune du
nord des yvelines de 1100 habitants
organisent pour la première fois de son
histoire le départ de la course au
soleil on écoute les réactions de petits
villages qui on a besoin de tes ville
pourquoi qu'on a départ on a besoin
voilà d'être accueilli dans
dans des villes et elles le font très
bien là il ya un bail est par exemple la
numéro un mondiale qui est là la valise
sur matin là le meilleur coureur
cycliste du monde
primo le glitch au classement yala
gratin mondial qui rase et c'est le
charme du vélo de pouvoir faire ça on
pourra port mener le psg doit-il sur
mention ni l'équipe de france de
football mais on peut emmener les
meilleures records en cd du monde
rapidement une petite réaction par
rapport aux 1,8 sur mansion thomas
voeckler qui est qui qui explique qu'on
ne peut pas emmener forcément des
grosses équipes partout par contre le
site il peut aller partout le cyclisme
peut passer dans tous les villages de
france
et oui bien sûr et dans tous les
villages du monde même bon encore que
certains s'y soit pas de la partie
vous voulez pas de bitume c'est un peu
plus compliqué de pouvoir les rejoindre
mais dans ce cas là on enverra les
champions de vtt
mais c'est vrai que l avantage du vélo
c'est ça c'est que on peut aller partout
où il peut il peut vraiment aller au le
vélo en fait c'est pas le sait pas le
spectateur qui vient à la rencontre du
sportif c'est le cyclisme qui vient à la
rencontre du spectateur sait où enfin la
rencontre du président se déplacer pour
pouvoir rencontrer ces sportifs l'allée
des sportifs viennent directement aux
spectateurs et c'est vrai que c'est ça
qui est magique dans le vélo c'est même
si le baht sage et très souvent rapide
et furtif
quand comme nous attendaient sur le bord
de la route pour voir passer un peloton
bas ça dure dix quinze secondes pour
parfois plusieurs heures d'attentes
parce que ben ali routes sont pas
toujours approchable dans les heures qui
précèdent le peloton mais c'est vrai que
voilà c'est ça fait partie du sahel
partie du folklore et de des choses
qu'on peut apprécier dans le vélo bien
chevalier
jeudi à joker là dessus parce que le
plus pur professionnels dont le styliste
se fait pas aux petits as et dispose de
pouvoirs de pouvoir continuer de pouvoir
continuer à exercer un travail
on va en parler pour le sport amateur un
peu plus tard c'est ça donne quand même
dès qu'un événement il est couvert par
la télévision ça donne quand même une
toute petite partie événementielle dans
ce dans ce paysage très très morose du
sport du sport amateur et 10 sport et
loisirs on a au moins pour se consoler
les droits télés et des couvertures
médiatiques et là en l'occurrence paris
nice a passé a fait exception à ça ça
nous donne encore une fois et on a parlé
souvent une occasion de montrer les dix
villes de vélo à la télévision
maintenant sur l'intérêt purement
sportif on a vu qu'il y avait qui
manquait grand nombre de grands nombres
de tête d'affiche sûr c'est sur ces
courses sur ces courses mythiques ses
courses importantes
on verra pour le reste de la saison
c'est ici si les autres événements si
les autres classiques on plus de succès
bon un peu mitigé sur celle sur 7 sur
cette organisation là en tout état de
cause a posteriori il a fait très beau
saint cyr a été mis en valeur les petits
villages aussi pour l'épauler d'autres
les autres maintenant espérons et
attendons la reprise du sport amateur
quel que soit le sport concerne oui
justement l'événement s'est déroulé dans
une bulle sanitaires les coureurs ont dû
passer des tests pcr avant le rendez
vous tout comme les journalistes et les
bénévoles autour de l'événement les
spectateurs n'ont pas pu approcher les
cyclistes sur le plan sportif peu de
stars pogab chars ou bernat les deux
derniers vainqueurs du tour de france ne
sont pas venus ni julian alaphilippe la
question sur cette thématique est ce que
c'était un paris-nice au rabais oui ou
non voter d'être partagée bon j'en je
vous vois sceptique je vais donner à
part l'agent et raul gens vont commencer
je vous donne ensuite la parole
cool on nous rit oui je suis sceptique
un petit peu pourquoi parce que c'est
compliqué en lui on vit quand même envie
quand même une période très très
compliqué donc on ne peut pas ne pas
tirer de 2,2 des plans sur la comète en
disant voilà il n'y avait pas et pas un
grand plateau ce paris nice paris nice
reste quand même une des grandes
classiques du cyclisme en france
qu'elles soient encore une fois de plus
et comme d'habitude sur les yvelines
c'est très très très bien et après mais
voilà c'est comme le golf dont l'un a
parlé les plateaux de c'est une chose la
course en est une autre
l'organisation est la même et en plus de
toute façon il n'ya pas de spectateurs
sur le bord du cul du de la route donc y
voilà pour moi c'est une réussite est
comme l'a dit pierre
il faisait très beau donc c'est très
très très bien et que ça continue comme
ça pour de belles années beaux mes
frères je précise un jean j'étais de
raul
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous est ce
que c'est une édition au rabais
peut-être cette année pour moi ça a déjà
le mérite d'avoir été organisée donc
toutes les tous les événements sportifs
tels qu'ils se tels qu'ils sont comment
dirais-je ne peut pas être évalué alors
à leur juste valeur
donc je trouve que malgré tout le paris
nice a conservé sa cote de popularité
est ce côté du voilà populaire proche
des gens et puis toujours cette réussite
du fait que ce soit dans les yvelines
quelques années une chambre s'était dit
dépassée par la vallée de chevreuse et
voilà c'est c'est quand même un endroit
où les les habitants sont concernées par
le vélo donc non pas au rabais au
contraire qui a eu le mérite d'exister
malgré la situation
vous êtes plutôt d'accord ce point de
vue là également qu'elle mérite
d'exister de toute façon ce que je
disais lors de la dernière émission il
va falloir s'habituer à cette situation
épidémique là sur le plan des des
supporters forcément quand on est
amoureux de sport amoureux de vélo
comme c'est le cas pour yann mais on
aime aussi qui est ce public là
forcément y'a pas il n'y a pas ce public
sur sur le paris nice il faut s'adapter
il n'y avait pas forcément les grands
champions mais il y avait il ya quand
même tonneau français il ya du bryan
coquard il ya du arnaud démare également
acquis et sur ce paris n'ose pas juin à
la fille par n'aura pas d'élan à la vie
un peu j'ai envie de vous dire et si on
se pose la question pour le paris nice
est ce que c'est une compétition au
rabais ou est-ce qu'on va se la poser
pour chaque compétition il y aura pas
forcément de public est ce que les jo
vont être au rabais parce qu'il y aura
pas de spectateurs internationaux je
pense que déjà il faut se réjouir que
des compétitions de sports
professionnels puissent se tenir
on va faire avec on va s'adapter avec
cette crise sanitaire qui nous agace
tout ça il faut le dire mais au moins au
moins les compétitions peuvent se tenir
et on dit on doit déjà s'en réjouir à
mon sens il ya du verrier moi je suis
désolé je vois pas du tout un paris-nice
au rabais parce que juste paugaite chars
et puis et puis il est au soin et bernal
ne sont pas venus ne sont pas venus déjà
ils viennent pas tous les ans c'est pas
un s'est passé c'est pas grave
maintenant j'ai quand même 2 td non on a
pris notre grille qui est numéro un
mondial qui a été présent oui en effet
c'est vrai qu' il manque julian
alaphilippe julian alaphilippe il est
parti en italie il a fait il a fait
s'est ralliée bianche ce week-end il
faut oser pas forcément une course qui
fait tout le temps là philippe et puis
voilà il ya aussi un calendrier qui se
complexifie un petit peu en cette
période c'est vrai qu'il ya aujourd'hui
la strade bianche laqué qui est une très
belle course italienne qui prend un peu
plus d'ampleur et qui apparemment
commencerait même à avoir le nom de 7e
monument derrière paris roubaix etc
donc c'est vrai que
là il ya quelque chose qui va peut-être
poser problème à paris nice dans
l'avenir et puis il ya toujours aussi
derrière cette semaine italienne avec
tirreno adriatico donc a toujours été en
concurrence avec paris nice tu sais tu
pas enfin voila moi je trouve que sam
bennett qui finit devant démarre à saint
cyr l'école c'est quand même des très
très bon sprinteur beaubelique arnaud
dénat re a gagné trois étapes et
dernière sur le sur le giro il avec ces
luttes c'est le sait le coureur qui a
gagné le plus de courses en 2000 en 2020
arnaud démare donc voilà lui il est
présent il adore paris nice on a on a
aussi réuni cavagna qui fait d'eux du
contre-la-montre hier qui voyait qu'il
fait du contre la montre qui était quand
même 6e et qui est un jeune rouleur qui
commence à gravir des échelons de la
hiérarchie internationale sur le sur le
contre la montre
i ça fait très longtemps qu'on avait pas
un français qui brille en contre la
montre et là on a vraiment quelqu'un qui
a une vraie valeur internationale
bien sûr dans une équipe dans une équipe
étrangère quick step comme comme peut
l'être
julian alaphilippe moi je trouve qu'on a
voilà c'est pas du tout voilà on a un
beau plateau
on ad on a des beaux coureurs voit on
alors seul bémol ça peut être le public
finalement c'est la problématique
aujourd'hui de toute façon que ce soit
un match de fou dans un stade où que ce
soit un match de rugby du quinze de
france
quand quand ils sont pas tous où que
vides et ben oui il manque du monde dans
les tribunes
et c'est vrai que ben c c'est dommage
j'ai j'ai mal quand je vois des matches
de tennis avec il ya personne dans les
tribunes je me dis mais comment ils font
alors qu'ils sont contents parce que du
coup pour la concentration ça aide mais
il manque quelque chose quoi c'est vrai
que c'est très très dur mais le public
fait partie aussi de l'exploit sportif
parfois hélas il n'y a pas ce ce
douzième homme
on dit souvent au football il n'est pas
présent dans les stades et sur les lieux
des compétitions
pierre chevalier voulais rajouter
quelque chose peut-être ajouter et
abondé dans le sens de ce que disent les
grecs tout à l'heure on a vraiment eu on
a vraiment cette impression là que ça
peut durer donc de toutes façons il faut
s'y habituer
il ya un problème d'équité sportive nous
voit d'ailleurs que au football
notamment ça n'est plus un avantage de
jouer à domicile français à huis clos
mais je crois que je crois comme comme
grégory que malheureusement au moins
pour 2021
il va falloir s'habituer à ça puisqu'on
parle déjà pour les jo-2012 stade
quasiment vide de spectateurs
internationaux et que dès que des
japonais donc faut s'y faire et les
nouvelles logique sportive par ce biais
là ils sont simplement que ça ne dure
pas après 2021 en tout cas le
département des yvelines va accueillir
le paris nice au minimum jusqu'en 2025
on continue à parler un cyclisme pas de
surprise aux élections de la fédération
française de cyclisme a annoncé comme le
grand favori michel callot le président
sortant été largement réélu à la tête de
la ffc
lors de l'assemblée générale au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines
il a battu son adversaire cyril à
guimard en engrangeant 93 42 % des
suffrages il sera donc en poste pour
quatre ans de plus on écoute michel
callot c'est notre interview express
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est évidemment une immense
satisfaction parce que ça a été
ces huit derniers mois très difficile
très difficile parce qu'on a quand même
été confronté à une campagne
particulièrement violente
et puis parce que en même temps il a
fallu gérer comme tout le monde mais
cette crise sanitaire
donc aujourd'hui j'ai un profond
soulagement parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'on peut continuer un travail qui est
qui est important et qui doit être
accomplie et puis la portée et l'ampleur
du score à donne une grande confiance et
surtout ça donne l'élan d'être porté par
par notre base
il va falloir comment qu'on regarde
comment on va sortir de cette crise et
quelles seront les conséquences pour
pour nous pour notre sport mais après
ces quatre années exaltantes et surtout
sur le territoire ici on va aller vers
les jeux olympiques de paris 2024 il y
aura tokyo quand même cette année donc
sur le plan sportif très dense pour nous
on a vraiment à réussir notre
transformation économique et puis
presque culturelle de notre fédération
au regard de la montée en puissance du
vélo dans notre société donc les
chantiers sont vraiment passionnant et
je le qualifierais plutôt comme une
commune olympiade où il faut pas manquer
la fenêtre de tir mais où ça va être
très stimulant on a un objectif pour
tokyo qui était celui de 1020 qu'on
maintient en 2021 qui est officiel
inquiète un objectif de 6 médailles
c'est un objectif que j'avais fixé au
début de la précédente olympiades qui
ambitieux très ambitieux mais on y va un
grand moment
on l'a entendu michel callot vu que la
france perd forme lors des prochains jo
de tokyo et surtout de paris la question
le président de la ffc fait-il gagner
des médailles aux équipes de france
est-ce que c'est lui finalement qui va
faire gagner des médailles
non oui pour vous gago rit oui pour vous
aux gens et raul vous êtes partagés
entre les deux d'accord on fait un petit
duel entre
entre vos grégory et pierre pierre c'est
vous qui commence et je n'attribue pas
autant de pouvoir un président d'un
président de fédération même si
évidemment son rôle est éminemment
important mais il l'est plus il n'est
plus sur la gestion du sport dans son
ensemble
que ce soit du plus petit licenciés
amateurs jusqu'au jusqu'aux
professionnels et pour répondre à cette
question de savoir si un président de
fédération fait gagner c'est on va dire
ces équipes fanions et en l'occurrence
l'équipe de france aux prochains jo
je pense que c'est lui prêter peut-être
trop trop de tout en revanche il a une
influence
il a une influence sur la tenue et la
portée du de son sport sur son sol et à
l'international des jeux olympiques il
ya un rôle évidemment important dans
l'information donc c'est aussi avec
toutes ces équipes le de serre éclore
des talents et là se poser la question
tout de suite après son élection de
savoir si ça va faire gagner des vies
d'ailleurs au japon j'ai déjà répondu je
réponds non parce que on va dire à un
grand nombre une grande quantité de
travail a déjà été fait jusqu'à
maintenant il y en aura d'autres
et puis ça reposera plus sur les épaules
des des champions le même et de leur
entraîneur de leur entourage au pouvoir
bien se préparer et bien performé lors
des pressions des prochaines années des
sciences hamasyan grégory
pierre pardon j'ai fait j'avais oublié
son nom est tu étais pas présent à la d1
fois pierre jetée déjà oubliée non il a
donné quelques éléments de réponse sans
dire à mon argumentaire effectivement
bien sûr qu'il n'est pas directement
impliqué dans les médailles mais il est
quand même au dessus c'est lui qui donne
la feuille de route c'est pas c'est pas
bien sûr michel callot qui va remporter
les médailles c'est les athlètes s'est
scellée sélectionneur derrière aussi
qu'ils vont prendre ses athlètes le dtn
aussi mais ils au dessus de tout ça
c'est lui qui va donner la feuille de
route c'est lui qui va nommer le
directeur technique national qui est en
ce moment
christophe mike christophe manas donc si
on regarde le bilan là sur ces quatre
dernières années en 2020 notamment il ya
eu des titres forcément des médailles et
il a forcément joué un rôle là dedans je
pense forcément à l'ats philippe son
titre sur la route à imola pauline
ferrand prévôt en vtt cross-country
donc il est là pour fixer le cas c'est
pas lui qui va directement gagné les
médailles mais c'est lui qui insuffle
cette dynamique qui va permettre au
final de remporter les médailles
raul vous étiez le plus indécis qui vous
a convaincu
voilà c'est comment le parfait le
parfait mélange de discours
le cyclisme c'est un sport qui ce qui se
distingue vraiment par sa diversité au
niveau de déjà des disciplines mais
aussi des publics
et puis alors il ya me reprendra si je
me trompe mais je pense qu'il est il est
largement plus se pratiquer en loisir
qu'en compétition en termes de nombre de
licenciés est pratiquement cessé mais
soucier par exemple dans les yvelines
5000 licenciés 1 mais beaucoup restent
de pratiquants forcément donc ensuite
leur président le président il est
présidente tous ces publics là et je
crois qu'en général il a quand même plus
d'impact sur le le sport pratiquer en
loisir en amateur faut pas se leurrer la
compétition c'est la haute compétition
phare dont c c'est aussi une histoire
d'argent il ya des histoires de sponsors
qui sont qui viennent s'ajouter à ça
qu'ils sont quand même assez indépendant
d'une fédération
donc alors après parce que je fais un
peu le rapprochement sport ou dans
lequel s'est complètement à part mais
effectivement je pense que dans le
cyclisme il ya peut-être qu'elle a fait
et plus partie prenante mais j'ai
souvent tendance à croire que le haut
niveau est tributaire effectivement d'un
règlement qui est qui est déterminé par
une fédé mais en général c'est quand
même une sphère qui est un petit peu
kira kira tâche est forcément à la fédé
mais qui est un petit peu à part qui
dépendent des athlètes et de leurs
partenaires à ses autres choses le haut
niveau voilà ça concerne un petit
pourcentage du public vient du guerrier
voilà vous avez été interpellé par raul
bien sûr que le nombre de pratiquants
mais c'est la même chose ça oui mais non
identiques en deux cycles de vélo avec
attention il faut quand même faire la
différence entre entre cyclistes et le
et le pratiquant le vélo
celui qui prend son vélo dimanche pour
aller fin de bal avec avec sa fille et
puis et puis et puis madame et les
connaissances y est et puis il fait du
vélo il fait pas du cyclisme il faut
quand même faire une grosse différence
pareil c'est la différence pour moi
entre le sportif et les loisirs
vous allez à la piscine vous allez faire
des mêmes des longueurs vous y allez
tous les dimanches à partir du moment où
vous ne faites pas de compétition vous
mettez pas un dossard sur le dos en
impression n'y a pas de dossard sur le
doubs mais pas seulement vous voyez vous
vous prenez pas le départ d'une
compétition pas ou ne fait pas de sport
vote une activité physique et c'est vrai
que c'est très très très clivant de ma
part mais moi je suis un compétiteur je
suis pas juste un sportif il fallait pas
du vélo fait du cyclisme
bah je fais plus de sport tas son nom
puisqu'il n'a pas de compétition
maintenant en ce moment je suis pas
sportif et et oui bien sûr maintenant je
fais de la compétition je fais du
cyclisme et je fais de la piste et c'est
vrai que j'ai un peu j'ai un peu de mal
avec ça et est donc si on prend le
nombre de pratiquants en athlétisme de
personnes qui font qu'ils font de
l'athlétisme ou alors des personnes qui
vont faire du jogging dimanche c'est
pareil la proportion est exactement la
même et aujourd'hui c'est un que c'est
quand même un gros gros problème parce
que la culture de la compétition on ne
l'a plus dans ce pays on fait du sport
on a la culture de l'art
la bonne de la bonne hygiène de vie
mais c'est vrai que faire du sport et
faire faire de la compétition c'est plus
dans l'essai plus dans les moeurs et
aujourd'hui ben voilà c'est vrai que ben
c'est pas c'est dommage parce que ben on
perd énormément de énormément de
personnes dans tous les sports on n'a
pas le vivier est la base qui
permettrait de pouvoir sortir plus
d'athlètes de haut niveau 8 800
licenciés en moins sur l'année 2020 dans
la fédération française de cyclisme
une perte qui s'explique aussi avec avec
la crise sanitaire totale à part tout en
voyant tout en france se tenir soit on
va revenir à michel callot est ce que il
fait gagner des médailles finalement
pour moi c'est pas du vin du présidentmd
c'est pas du tout le président qui fait
gagner des médailles
c'est alors c'est une stratégie mais
mais c'est pas lui qui l'a mon
application déjà ces deux sont des
discussions avec plusieurs personnes
pour définir cette propre stratégie
c'est pas juste lui qui dit kiki qui
décide et il fixe pas un câble comme le
disait gribouille finalement ouais mais
c'est pas dans ces cas là enfin oui on
dit aussi c'est qu'il ya un skipper aux
dents quand c'est qu'en cdd course d
course en équipage
il ya le chef d'équipage et c'est lui
skipper qui l'a franchement c'est quand
mes athlètes qui passe la ligne
d'arrivée ou qui marque les buts pour
pour les footballeurs c'est pas le
président de la fédération qui fait qu'
on est champion du monde ou pas quoi je
parle de football voire un peu plus
noël le graet qu'installe didier
deschamps comme sélectionneur s'est pas
déterminant selon toi pour quasiment vie
on est sûre si parce que didier
deschamps ont tous un an plus tard je
suis fan on ne fait pas ça parce que ça
n'empêche que quand on reste dans le
dans le choix du dû dès le choix du
président et bien sûr que en plus didier
deschamps aujourd'hui c'est un mec qui
il a tout ce qui va te mettre en place
il l'a gagné mais aujourd'hui on n'a pas
ce didier deschamps dans le vélo on n'a
pas le didier deschamps comme peuvent
labatut l'avoir l'attend d'athlétisme le
dtn est datée ti je trouve qu'il
l'ancien qui était un ancien lutteur en
plus j'ai
gal nous et bien une photo c'est vous
qui votez d'habitude c'est vrai que
c'est vrai qu'il portait le projet je
suis d'accord et ben en vélo je suis
désolé on n'a pas les dtn qui peuvent
avoir cette aura et
maintenant sur la route je trouve que
thomas voeckler a ouai c'est peut-être
la bonne personne c'est peut-être la
bonne personne parce que c'est un
coureur récent c'est un coureur jeunes
et ben oui il allie la le hilal bon il a
le bon goût il a le bon truc mais ça
reste le directeur sportif de la route
jésus pas je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
encore le qu'ils aient toutes les toutes
les cordes pour pouvoir tout diriger je
pense qu'on a dit on a des choses à des
progrès encore à faire jean très
rapidement vous a pas entendu sur le
sujet après on passe à la prochaine
thématique
mais très rapidement moi j'étais un
petit peu indécis mais il n'y avait pas
de déni comme de khost est pas là
possible
simplement je dis qu il m fait partie
quand même il c'est pas lui qui gagne
des médailles c'est sûr mais c'est lui
qui est quand même la politique de la
fédération et qui met en place notamment
tout ce qui est des tn entraîneur et
pourquoi pas aussi en communication et
en relations avec les principaux
responsables
les membres de l'équipe de france et qui
va qui va aller qui vont aller à ses
prochains jeux olympiques
donc pour moi il a me fais partie un
président c'est important jusque là on
parle pour poule
bien sûr il est président de la
fédération du bas vers le haut mais en
ce qui concerne les jeux olympiques là
il est quand même
il a quand même une part de
responsabilité par rapport à sa
politique
voilà il faut forcément un ancien
cycliste pour diriger la ffc oui alors
moi moi je suis quand même impôt parce
qu'on a vu on a vu on a vu on l'a vu au
tennis on a vu au rwanda notamment cité
des joueurs des assiettes joueurs de
rugby qui avait été président du du
tennis ou du handball moi je suis
partisan quand on ne connaît jamais
aussi bien sa fédération que lorsqu'on à
pratiquer la discipline
donc je suis effectivement pour un
président qui est issu de
de la discipline en question chez lequel
est un très bon coureur de première
catégorie dans sa carrière un faux pas
faux pas le dénigrer
c'est pas un niveau que tout le monde
peut atteindre 1 oui tout à fait il a
gagné plusieurs plusieurs courses alors
on va maintenant parler de rugby la
décision est tombée la fédération
française à l'issue de son bureau
fédéral a annoncé l'arrêt des saisons
amateurs 2020 2021 en raison de la
situation sanitaire en france un
calendrier impossible à tenir
la ffr a notamment décidé de figer les
montées et les descentes pour tous les
niveaux sauf dérogation obtenue du
ministère en charge des sports
ce sera donc une saison blanche pour
tous les clubs libinois la reprise de la
pratique sportive à l'entraînement
pourrait quant à elle être envisagée
dans léa prochaines semaines la question
sur ce thème la décision est elle
logique oui ou non vous étés décision
logique
oui oui je crois que tout le monde est
unanime je veux donner la parole à à
raul raul
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
décision je pense qu'elle va dans la
dans la continuité de ce qui a été de ce
qui a été imposé jusqu'à présent après
si on veut si on veut le plus vite
possible
no sport pratiqué comme il l'était pour
peut-être passé par là si toutefois
pierre et jean vivais ça comme une
injustice dans ma branche est dans notre
dame en sport c'est exactement la même
chose
seuls les professionnels en droit de de
continuer à participer à des
compétitions les amateurs et encore nous
est encore pire maintenant les faux alex
couvre la rhino donc même les chevaux
sont confinés n'ont pas le droit de
circuler donc je fais face au ski à ce
cet enfermement du sport donc voilà
j'aurais tendance à à considérer que
c'est que c'est normal et c'est normal
et que que tout est bon pour que le plus
vite possible nous sortions de la pierre
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais moi je
suis je suis évidemment extrêmement déçu
mais pas du tout surpris
on en parlait depuis depuis quelques
temps maintenant j'ai beaucoup de
beaucoup de mots en équipe pour
expliquer mes sensations et je pense des
raisons qui expliquent cette cette
décision le premier mot qui les parents
aient cessées solidus est celui d'un dj
pense qu'elle vient au dilemme pour les
fédérations et des idées pour arriver à
cette décision finale l'un qui a duré
longtemps le plus ça dure et moi on
avait le l'espoir parce que là c'est une
question d'équité c'est une question de
sécurité des joueurs
c'est une question de solidarité et qui
va à l'encontre de la combi quand on
arrive à une deuxième saison
bancal on va dire de la saison 2010 9
2020 a été évitée banque a terminé
rebelote redonner de cette saison là on
arrive à des considérations qui au delà
de la partie équité sportive et
équilibre financier
pas de la sécurité des joueurs c'est à
dire que de toute façon compte plus que
tout ça avance et plus on aurait plus on
a de chance car il fallait de toute
façon parle du rugby
en l'occurrence on prévoir une période
de réathlétisation de reprise du contact
puisque là nous sommes quasiment quatre
mois presque 5 de pratique du rugby où
il faut comme comme l'évoqué rao
il faut quand même il faut quand même le
dire on a la possibilité de jouer au
rugby sans contact et en protocole iii
du covin donc ça fait quasiment 4 5
points qu'on était comme ça donc il
aurait fallu se remettre remettre la
machine en marche pour éviter les
blessures
bon malheureusement c'était une c'est
une décision qui est tout à fait logique
facilite pas la vie des clubs amateurs
qui regardent leurs grands frères
grandes soeurs du sport professionnel
continuer à jouer dans des stades vides
pour raccrocher le sujet qu'on ait
évoqué précédemment c'est que
malheureusement doit s'y faire juste
espérer que ça ne passe pas les saisons
la saison 2021 2022
retrouver le chemin des terrains avec le
compact mais malheureusement dans ce
contexte actuel avec tous les paramètres
pris en compte c'est une décision qui
est tout à fait logique gens comment les
joueurs ont réagi à cette annonce dans
votre club de gif sur yvette
tout le monde est déçu de manger des
cieux personne n'est surpris c'est la
logique c'est la logique des choses
actuellement on peut pas on peut pas
faire autrement on voit mal on voit mal
comment on pourrait vous aujourd'hui
dire allez hop c'est bon allez vous
allez jouer avec un petit bal aux
souhaits de terrain alors que tous les
lieux publics les restaurants restent
fermés
donc non c'était la logique et
sportivement mais on ne peut pas faire
autrement je rejoins pierre lorsqu'il
dit que maintenant il n'y a plus qu'à
croiser les doigts que ça ne ne continue
pas sur la prochaine saison
parce que il ya déjà mais on n'est pas
les seuls
mais bon puisqu'on parle rugby il ya
déjà mon avis hein
un gros travail là de deux remises de
remise en place et de remise en forme
physiquement mentalement parce que les
joueurs qui ne qui sont restés autant de
temps sans jouer ça va mon avis faire
beaucoup de dégâts notamment aux que
physique je pense que mentalement aussi
j'ai bien peur malheureusement
contrairement à une trêve qui durent pas
très longtemps
et puis on se remet très vite dans le
bain là ça fait une grande période où je
pense qu'on va laisser un petit peu de
monde sur le côté ou quelques joueurs
pourraient avoir goûté le fait qu'ils
aient plus de rugby et que finalement ça
ne remonte pas trop donc voilà on risque
à mon avis de d'avoir un retour
de saison assez compliquée j'ai des
cyclistes qui nous ont dit qu'ils
savaient plus faire du vélo un non mais
c'est vrai qu'il juge je suis copain
d'accord avec jean c'est à dire qu' il
va falloir que tout le monde réussisse à
reprendre les habitudes et ça va être
très très très très long on vous a pas
entendu jean vous avez dit tragique il
remettra la scène merci de préciser le
nouveau match qui démarre comme comme
gens commençaient à elle évoqué le
nouveau match qui démarre ça va être de
garder nos licences et là on a on a un
gros combat un gros match de première mi
temps là qui est qui démarre jusqu'en
septembre
c'est de pouvoir malgré le fait qu'on
ait gardé le lien avec nos licenciés
d'une manière ou d'une autre sur quoi
par la communication soit par le
protocole iii avec du n'est pas parce
des tapas de rugby comme ça ils nous ont
permis de continuer l'école de rugby
c'est de ne pas perdre de licenciés et
de faire en sorte que qu'il ne se soit
pas tourner vers d'autres d'autres
sports où d'autres activités pendant
pendant cette période un peu trouble qui
viennent de s'écouler vous attendent à
combien de licenciés peut-être en moins
à versailles pierre alors grâce au
travail de tous les bénévoles de
l'addition n'est pas salé c'est à dire
qu'on a on était assis 106 102 licenciés
d'année dernière et on va on va terminer
la saison la saison 2020-2021 aux
alentours de 580 donc on est vraiment on
est pas plaint à d'autres clubs mais
maintenant il ya l'été il y a
le retour à la normale plus ou moins
long donc ça peut être une crainte de 5
à 10% tout écrit qui confond la durée
ils voulaient intervenir
je voulais intervenir juste pour aller
dans le même sens que mes partenaires
dire ça fait mal forcément c'est sûr
qu'on a eu le petit sucre à la bouche du
début de saison alors là je parle on
parle du rugby mais c'est la même
situation pour les autres sports
amateurs mais ça devenait de plus en
plus difficile avec cette situation qui
dure des dates qui allait de plus en
plus être difficile à trouver dans un
calendrier pour terminer la saison et
c'est vrai ça a été dit aussi
s'entraîner s'entraîner deux avec une un
petit protocole pas de contacts ça rien
à voir avec les matches de compétition
donc il faut aussi se ré athlétisation
ça devenait aussi compliqué pour les
organismes
donc oui forcément ça fait mal mais je
vais je vais dans le sens des camarades
pour dire que asselah la seule solution
qui se présentaient à l'instar de la
nationale 2 en football qui devait
reprendre et finalement on a fait le
choix de pala fait reprendre vous y avez
cru ou en début de saison peut-être sur
une saison normale
cette année quand on quand on s'est
lancé dans là dans la saison qu'on
sortait de cet été où le virus avait un
peu moins circuler oui il ya peut-être
eu un peu un peu de naïveté notre part
de 10 de se dire qu'on pouvait on
pouvait renouer tranquillement avec le
monde d'avant malheureusement
cette situation sanitaire ce virus n'est
n'ai jamais vu et n'a pas forcément fini
de livrer tous ses verdicts ça va se
poursuivre on en revient à ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure il faut s'habituer
à ces deux situations et vivre avec
genre voulais rajouter quelque chose
très rapidement très rapidement un
simple hommage c'est que au niveau du
temps au niveau du talent à la
fédération n'avait pu non plus du tout
le choix dans les dates pour mener à
bien et à terme se chargent de la merci
jean merci pour toutes ces précisions
alors maintenant on va passer à notre
page débats alors on va maintenant
passer à l'envolée de grégory le moment
fort de cette émission alors de quoi
allez vous nous parlez grégory d'un
yvelinois bien sûr et on était tous
heureux forcément après sa victoire tony
yoka le boxeur de chanteloup les vignes
a vaincu vendredi 5 mars le belge joëlle
tambouille dzeko c'était à la hache
arena de nantes et big jo a dû rendre
les armes au 12e round après que le
français lui est asséné un enchaînement
de droite et un uppercut fatale le
poussant à abandonner pour la première
fois en 21 combats lors de ce duel tony
yoka été dominateur il a paru concentrée
et appliquée n'est pas tombé dans le
piège tendu par le belge son adversaire
lui avait adressé effectivement une
claque la veille lors de la pesée pour
essayer de le faire sortir de ses gonds
ça n'a pas marché dixième victoire en
dix combats pour tenir yoka et dont 8
avant la limite c'est son premier titre
professionnel
cette ceinture de l'union européenne
c'est la première étape de la conquête a
commenté le champion olympiques 2016
car l'objectif de l'artiste sont
sûrement devenir champion du monde des
poids lourds il s'est donné quinze
combats pour y parvenir depuis son
entrée chez les pros en juin 2010 est un
juteux contrat d'ailleurs été signé avec
canal + pour suivre cette épopée
un chemin qui est encore long il faut le
dire pour le numéro 13 mondial
l'illinois a pris du retard par rapport
aux tops mondiaux qu'il tente de
rejoindre les britanniques tyson fury
anthony joshua ou encore l'américain a
démenti et wilder au bout de quatre ans
chez les professionnels eux avaient déjà
près de 20 combats à leur actif tony
yoka on a 10 pour le moment anthony
joshua par exemple était devenu
champion du monde des poids lourds en
2016 quatre ans seulement après sa
médaille olympique à londres m et le
champ couvert a été freinée par la crise
sanitaire et surtout par sa suspension
d'un an pour trois manquements à des
contrôles antidopage alors peut-il
devenir champion du monde j'ai envie de
dire pourquoi pas il faut forcément
passer pour se faire par des victoires
contre des adversaires de plus grande
renommée
tambwe dzeko était moins bien classé que
les deux précédents adversaires de tony
yoka à savoir hammer et duo passe est
l'athlète de 28 ans a d'ailleurs été
souvent raillé pour avoir battu je cite
des videurs de macumba c'est
l'expression qui a été utilisée
notamment par julien lorcy ancien
champion du monde des poids légers qui
avait tenu ces propos dans une interview
à la presse et donc il y à une série de
dix victoires certes contre des
adversaires plus petit mais qu'il y aura
a permis tout de même de se faire la
main et de prendre confiance et donc
prochaine étape j'ai envie de dire
vaincre mieux classé que lui ce pourrait
être john joyce est 12e mondial et
détenteur de la ceinture ebu c'est
l'autre titre européen le prestigieux
tony yoka était d'ailleurs devenu
champion olympique est devant l'anglais
en 2016
faisons notre revanche des jeux
maintenant je sais que tu là veulent
interpeller yoka sur twitter et qui
espère donc affronter joyce dès
septembre
une victoire pourrait lui permettre de
challenge et ensuite un top 10 mondial
pourquoi pas en dire with junior le
mexicain qui est déjà venu à bout
d'anthony joshua pour le moment aucun
programme aucun combat n'est programmée
mais le français qui s'entraîne à
houston compte bien sur son promoteur
bob arum pour le faire connaître
outre-atlantique tony yoka se fixe
d'ailleurs comme objectif 2022 pour
cette ceinture mondiale irait gratte il
a dès l'an prochain
je trouve tout de même que c'est encore
un peu prématurée la question sur ce
thème tous liés aux caps il devenir
champion du monde de boxe
oui ou non voter oui pour vous vous êtes
mitigé gens oui mais pas en 2022 bombe
alors jean vous qui avait été un videur
au macumba qu'est ce qu'ils en pensaient
mais c'est notre vie radiations je suis
mitigé parce que grégory l'a dit la
route est longue
la route est longue et elle a une fois
de plus on l'avait avait déjà débattu
sur le plateau mais une fois de plus il
prend un biberon candidats on va dire
qu'ils montent de juste deux catégories
c'était je crois
son premier ou un de ses premiers
combats un poids lourd qui monte de
justin catégorie donc ça faut pas dire
que ce soit vraiment une référence et on
peut pas dire qu'il ait survolé en plus
ce ce combat je les regardais tous les
rounds se se ressembler jusqu'au dernier
où il a accéléré peu et et l'autre il a
abandonné mais sinon on ne peut pas on
peut pas dire qu'il ait vraiment qu'il
est vraiment dominer un gars qui a pas
capable de cas déjà en plus
kiki qui n'a pas d'expérience à ce
niveau est catégorie de poids
et puis là je voulais juste aussi
rajouter un petit truc c'est que moi je
commence à me perdre un peu avec ses
ceintures la haie et c'est parce que là
je suis un peu perdu il est légèrement
en dessous en sont les spécialistes de
la ceinture ebu le but c'est vraiment
champion d'europe
l'union européenne s'est un petit peu en
dessous ben ouais d'accord mais là j ai
trop trop trop trop peut-être du recul à
7 mais voilà il ya déjà riez vous qui
n'êtes jamais rentrés macumba qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
oui oui mais les videurs été beaucoup
plus costaud que moi à l'époque donc
c'était très très content je courrai
plus vite
j'ai la même sensation qu'en fin
lui-même discours que jean c'est vrai
que le problème de la de la boxe c'est
qu'il ya trop de fédérations trop de
ceinture être au titre maintenant
ceinture première ceinture très bien
maintenant son objectif et je ne
comprends c'est d'être champion du monde
parce que dans ceux du genre de sport il
n'y a que ça qui compte
alors moi je dis que oui peut être
champion du monde tout simplement parce
que il a 28 ans alors oui je crois que
ses adversaires ne sont pas beaucoup
beaucoup plus vieux que lui mais pour
voir je suis à 31 ans à sa et 35 ans
pour wilders maintenant maintenant voilà
un peu plus ce soir un peu plus vieux et
donc ça lui laisse le temps de pouvoir
murray a maintenant un champion du monde
poids lourds
ben ça se fait pas ça se fait pas comme
ça
donc les sur le grimp est tranquillement
dans la hiérarchie il a une boxe il a
son style
il a il peut être percutant donc il est
champion olympique
alors oui ces amateurs etc il est
champion olympique il faut qu' il faut
qu'il aille qui rentre dedans et ça va
se faire petit à petit maintenant je
pense que lors il s'est beaucoup plus
qui est beaucoup plus un petit peu notre
spécialiste boxe en plus de notre
spécialisée dans l'équitation vous avez
fait de la boxe
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous en
fait je commence à y croire je commence
à y croire parce que depuis qu'il
s'entraîne aux états unis il à vaches il
a bien amélioré sa box le combat qui a
eu lieu la semaine dernière c'était
difficile de faire mieux parce qu'il
était en face de quelqu'un qui cherchait
absolument le chaos et est qui qui se
protéger à tout prix donc voilà alors ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'il fait face tony
il fait face à à quelque chose d'assez
difficile c'est que je pense que depuis
l'histoire de la boxe dans la catégorie
poids lourd n'a jamais été aussi relevé
dans son top 10 peut-être à l'époque de
ali frasier l'histoire effectivement la
v3 trois dinosaures qui surplombait la
discipline mais là c'est raide c'est
vrai que c'est très difficile de se
faire un chemin
il a pris du retard
pour certaines raisons jeu
je crains que la seule chance qu'ils
puissent lui être tendu ces deux d'avoir
un appel en en anglais un title shot
c'est-à-dire un combat avec un champion
du monde tout de suite parce que sinon
le parce que l'on parle que des
champions mais en numéro deux il ya des
boxeurs comme comme luis ortiz comme en
deux camps de ruiz on en a parlé aussi
comme deal alouettes qui sont qui sont
des challengers très très sérieux et qui
ont déjà inquiété wilder et je suis à
deux reprises donc bon le problème c'est
que ces boxeurs là pour qu'ils aient ces
opportunités il faut il faut qu'ils
fassent forte impression et c'est ce qui
manque encore un petit peu dans les
combats de tony hawk a qui n'ont pas
disputé encore avec des têtes de série
c'est que ces combats manque d'éclat ils
sont
ça se soit c'est gagné aux points ça
c'est des chaos qui vont au 12e d'eau
donc c'est il me manque encore un petit
peu d'éclat pour qu'on lui offre cette
chance là et c'est pour ça que c'est pas
c'est même pas que c'est pas écrit
qu'ils puissent le qu'ils puissent être
un pion et déjà une capture va lui être
donné et ça c'est pas sûr c'est pas sûr
parce que voilà champion olympique c'est
vrai que ce n'est pas rien mais ça ça ne
définit pas sur l'itinéraire
professionnel mais la mémé par contre il
a fait d'énormes progrès ça c'est sûr on
l'a montré moi je
honnêtement je suis très content de son
combat il pouvait pas faire autrement
avec quelqu'un en face de lui qui
prenait 0 risqué qui attendait le chaos
et je trouve qu'il s'est très bien
débrouillé oui vous les résultats
raul évoqué le cas de mohamed a dit je
crois qu'il a fallu vingt combats
mohammad ali pour décrocher une couronne
mondiale donc on en est à la moitié
finalement non qui lui reste encore du
temps après le ce que je disais c'est
l'objectif de 15 combats 2022 gg je
reste figé sur sur cette position je
pense que ça peut être difficile pour
dès l'année prochaine j'ai entendu ou
pour d'autres champions aussi une
trentaine de combat pour devenir
champion du monde donc il
il a encore le temps et il a l'âge pour
lui je dirais dans l'est dans les
challengers dont vous pouvez parler mais
la plupart sont somptueux cuite face
face à des adversaires comme ceux à qui
tony hawk a fait face les les garçons
qu'on voit aujourd'hui être champion du
monde
c'était bouclé au premier rand c'est ça
que je veux expliquer en fait c'était
c'est elle ou alors larbitre larbitre
arrêtez tout de suite le combat il y
avait une vraie différence de niveau là
il perd déjà vous pensez que c'est un
petit peu plus poussif raul pardon vous
pensez que c'est peut-être un petit peu
plus poussif ces combats oui oui je suis
normalement pour pour espérer être
champion du monde face au faso aux
combattants auxquels il a fait face
ça doit être plus expéditif que ça donc
soit il doit trouver il doit passer un
cap
soirée lui manque une petite étincelle
il a connu un combat qui l'a réglé au
monde une mine au monde au moins deux
sur un premier round le combat d'avants
je croise introduit au passe autour du
repas sur moi c'était au 3ème rang
devenu rapidement un ancêtre du crédit
du de l'abbé gérard chevallier
il a il a 28 ans il lui reste quand même
du temps et lili les paluds finalement
tony hawk annoncé qu'en boxe on peut on
peut boxer jusqu'à 40 ans deux fois
peut-être même plus et tout et tout ça
tout ça c'est une question de maturité
est question de personnalité on entend
parler un petit peu avant cette édition
avec raul notamment c'est c'est la
question qui me restent en suspens au
delà de ses qualités athlétiques et
c'est que des combattants ce avec une
vraie personnalité et un os ce mental de
puncheur qui fait que dans ceux dans ce
texte
et dans ce secteur des lourds qui est
maintenant très starisé on en compte en
parler en bien ancrée très américanisée
ça fait le show c'est à dire que il faut
qu'il se passe quelque chose à la pesée
n'a il promis pour le clac clac
en pause et ça pose sa pause le match
en gros dés qu dit moi je fais ça parce
que je veux munissez dans sa tête pour
pouvoir
pour moi le faire douter les énervés
parce que généralement la colère il
mauvaise conseiller en boxe elle peut
soit se faire péter un plomb soit soit
se faire piéger de se délier de son
comparez donc toute la question est de
savoir si si nos cadences à 28 ans et
dans les années qui viennent d'avoir
suffisamment de moyens suffisamment de
30 voire de sagesse et de l'est de
stratégie trop court aller se frotter
aux meilleurs le aux meilleurs puncheurs
qui comme l'a dit raul démarre tous très
vite et donc il faut être tout de suite
tout de suite efficace fort d'efforts
aussi dans la tête
en plus de l'aide dans les points ce
sera le déjà le mot de la fin dans cette
émission à merci à tous d'avoir
participé
alors c'est déjà la fin de cette
émission va terminer comme d'habitude
par une citation aujourd'hui je vous
propose une citation de pierre de
coubertin le père des jeux olympiques
modernes le plus important aux jeux
olympiques n'est pas de gagner mais de
participer car l'important dans la vie
mais point le triomphe mais le combat je
vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
oui